bei mir so nah heißt das neue Album von
Cassandra Steen und der Titel ist auch
Programm das ganze ist ihr nah und zwar
auch in der Form dass sie sich neu
erfunden hat so ein bisschen mit dem
Album es geht nicht nur um Balladen es
sind auch ganz andere Sachen drauf es
ist wirklich spannend zu hören und die
Geschichte dahinter die ist eigentlich
noch spannender wie es dazu gekommen ist
wie Sie den Antrieb gekriegt hat
hier was neues auszuprobieren das
erzählt sie bei klicksumiert wir haben
sie getroffen hier in Köln im
Hotelgarten des Radisson Blu
halli hallo
meine erste Frage ist immer wie ist die
Lage wie ist die Lage angenehm sehr gut
jetzt wo es so Frühling wird und warm
das ist ja immer das motiviert ja ganz
anders ich meine Winter ist dann immer
schon zum Kuscheln oder auch auf der
Couch sitzen mit Freunden bisschen
Spiele spielen durch drehen aber so ist
auch gut kann man auch draußen machen
jetzt das ist das ein guter Zeitpunkt um
Album zu veröffentlichen
ich würde es doch schwer hoffen
kann ja sein dass man sagt ach nee
lieber im Winter
Konzertsäle oder lieber im Sommer
draußen ich weiß es gar nicht was ist
ein guter Zeitpunkt ich soll für diese
Platte ist tatsächlich eher so Frühling
Sommer da wird jetzt eigentlich auch gar
nicht so sehr Konzert Seele wie ihr
Festivals also ich machen wollen können
ja dann eh jetzt dann im Herbst drauf
freuen wir uns natürlich aber wir haben
also ich habe mich jetzt auch für neue
Sachen entschieden schnellere Sachen und
das performt man doch dann gerne draußen
oder Sonne wobei so mein Gefühl ist es
sind so zwei Pole es ist eben schneller
es ist Tanz es ist ähm Party es ist aber
auch Gefühl das darf natürlich nicht
fehlen das muss ja trotzdem in die Tiefe
gehen ja also wir wollten schon ein
bisschen dass das ausgeflippt sowas auch
mal ausprobieren aber mal gucken wo denn
tatsächlich meine Grenzen sind ziemlich
nur Balladen abgeben aber es ist
muss trotzdem an Tiefe natürlich haben
aber immer noch nicht erreicht die
Grenzen nein
gibt es etwas wo du sagen würdest nie da
traue ich mich nicht ran das ist mir
vielleicht zu heavy oder zu darum geht
es nicht es geht immer nur darum es ist
passen muss also es kann irgendwann mal
ein Heavy Metal Stück kommen aber es
muss passen ja okay ja also ich bin
offen für alles an Musik ich glaube es
war eher ist weil das Problem dass man
mich aus dieser Schublade aus dieser
Balladen Schublade erstmal raus
bringt aber man muss erstmal rausfinden
was passt denn das jetzt kannte man mich
eben nur unter der laden wir haben dann
das wegen nur beladen zugeschickt
bekommen oder
das beste haben wir eigentlich schon
abgeliefert also es kommt sicherlich
noch was aber
das heißt bis jetzt einfach noch nicht
so dabei dass man sagt oh ganz toll
Blabla und wenn dann ist natürlich auf
der Platte aber wir haben dann ein paar
Antworten darauf gefunden
hast du denn ist zu dir passend was muss
etwas haben dass es zu dir passt
es muss trotzdem authentisch sein das
muss trotzdem werden wir ausstrahlen es
muss trotzdem als Musik begleiten können
und dürfen also diese Möglichkeit muss
offen bleiben es muss Musik sein und
dann passt es auch okay was ist nicht
nur Musik
nicht musik ist wenn es zu sehr
abgestimmt ist dass es gefallen muss ja
okay also es muss sich auch für mich
zumindest als Künstler muss sich so wohl
fühlen dass es sagt das möchte ich aber
auch rausbringen und genau so will ich
es rausbringen und dann gucken wir mal
ob ob es Menschen findet ja aber nicht
dann so dieses okay so und so und so und
dann passiert das tatsächlich meistens
fühle ich das damit nicht
ja ja
nicht so sehr
diesen typischen Ablauf haben
genau
gebt alles was hast du da jetzt für ein
warum habt ihr das als Single aus
ausgewählt gibt alles hat mir so sehr
gefallen weil ich mir das Instrument und
habe ich mich gleich verliebt weil das
eigentlich ziemlich hip hopig ist und
ich habe es eigentlich sofort an Jay
sehr erinnert
natürlich jetzt mit dem Verlauf des
Textes ist es dann eine Mischung
geworden eine gute aber auch die die
Aussage grundsätzlich von gibt alles ist
sehr passend für mich auch weil ich
natürlich die ganze Zeit was ist diese
Platte jetzt angeht doch eine Steigerung
wollte von der letzten und dann auch
jeden mitreißen musste ich weiß dass
einige mich schon fast umbringen wollten
weil ich dann ankam wir müssen auf eine
Maßstab von dem Prinz weil ich jetzt auf
diesem Konzert war und es war so toll so
alles umgeworfen komplett neu angefangen
aber es ist gut geworden wir sind ja
immer noch nicht auf diesem Maßstab aber
man kann sich ja nach wie versteigern
das ist aber auch eine sehr hohe Latte
natürlich
aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein Maßstab
den ich mir nach wie versetzen möchte
das macht ja auch Spaß also es kommen
tolle Sachen dabei raus ist das so etwas
das oder ein Punkt wenn man sagt gibt
alles dass man sich so hohe Ziele setzt
das heißt hohe Ziele es soll man darf
sich das glaube ich ruhig zutrauen also
vielleicht dann auch schnell verwechselt
dass man sagt wie krass wenn man sich so
hohe Ziele setzt aber warum denn nicht
mein Mann schafft es ja also man kann es
schaffen das hat immer auf diese einen
Ebene zu bleiben man muss es ja nicht
gleich von hier bis dahin schaffen ich
glaube dann eher das Ziel kann da oben
sein aber muss dann sich schon bewusst
machen dass man so ankommt ja
stufenweise aber man kommt an und ich
glaube das ist wichtig woher hast du
dieses Selbstvertrauen
ach das kann das habe ich jetzt auch
nicht so lange es ist das wächst gerade
alles aus kommt unter anderem auch von
Familie und nach wie vor also eigentlich
immer immer wieder von meinem Großvater
erzähl mal über dein groß war der muss
ja unglaublicher Mensch gewesen sein
Essen unglaublicher Mensch er hat mich
großgezogen mit meiner Großmutter und er
hat mir immer er ist da vielleicht aber
auch sehr typisch amerikanisch hat mir
immer gesagt dass ich auch alles kann ja
also egal wie verrückt oder und von ihm
kommt auch so ein bisschen so so gib
alles egal was ich mir aussuchen was ich
später machen möchte daran soll ich die
beste sein
und das hat er mir wirklich nah ans Herz
gelegt und tut's immer noch und das war
von Anfang an so klar dass Musik dein
Weg ist
das einfach nur alles klar ich glaube so
richtig richtig klar was tatsächlich als
ich nimmerei gesehen habe die gerade
rausgekommen ist und die sehr
authentisch war trotz ihres Talents ist
ja riesig war also für die Zeit auch
also sie war so normal und wirklich
sagen kann oh mein Gott ist eine von uns
an mit so einem Talent und sie ist
trotzdem normal geblieben das ist lange
lange her
mittlerweile hat auch die Branche sie
ein bisschen eingeholt aber ist nicht
mehr so ganz normal ist glaube ich auch
schwer
das wird nicht nur sie alleine sondern
das ganze Umfeld aber
sie war trotzdem die größte Inspiration
davor habe ich natürlich Michael Jackson
gehört auch wieder über den Großvater
der der das mit nach Hause gebracht hat
der auch ein Fan war
so richtig dass man sagt okay ich gehe
jetzt auch auf die Bühne ich war
natürlich fasziniert von dem Videos und
das auch so schüchtern war und mit
Sicherheit reden lassen zumindest von
dem Spielberg aber
da war so nicht so klar so okay das will
ich machen ich habe auch wenig
Bühnenauftritte von ihm gesehen das war
eine eher Videos die die richtig cool
waren aber Maria war dann so dieser
Auftritt
und wann war der denn klar dass du das
so kannst also
dieses du kannst alles wie gesagt das
haben wir schon öfter mal Interviews
gehabt das wird ja vielen DSDS
Teilnehmern auch gesagt und sie können
es aber da habe ich dann auch ein
bisschen gekämpft weil ich dann gedacht
da wäre gut oder ist einfach so jeder
sagt und selber hat man aber keine
Ahnung was dann tatsächlich also
deswegen sind auch meine Maßstäbe so
hoch deswegen Vergleich also das heißt
Vergleiche versuche ich nach dem zu
kommen was ein Prince macht oder eine
Maria oder oder auch eine Gaga also
einfach die wirklich alles geben und
überall mit involviert sind und auch an
sich glauben und sich aber auch
verbessern das auch nicht aufhören also
oft gesagt du brauchst doch gar kein
Gesangsunterricht ist würde man niemals
mit Fußballer sagen dass sie nicht mehr
trainieren muss
macht man nicht
und deswegen wird weiter Unterricht
genommen bei Leuten die es wissen
also die Ahnung haben und die mir dann
sagen können und die mir dann bzw auch
schon gesagt haben du hast ein Talent
und die das dann auch unterstützt haben
also hatte ich dann auch viel Glück also
es ist nicht nur diese eigene wo ich
sage okay ich ich kann jetzt fünf
Minuten und bin jetzt ein großer Sänger
also ich hatte da schon noch Leute die
in der Branche wirklich fest sind
und und wenn man dann auch von ihrer
Aussage her Vertrauen haben kann weil
sie da wirklich geschult sind auch haben
die das auch so entwickelt weil das habe
ich nämlich auch festgestellt beim Hören
deines Albums das geht sehr in die Tiefe
das geht aber auch in die Höhe da habe
ich durchaus am Mariah Carey gedacht
das ist beabsichtigt gewesen also von
denen die es hören nicht
was also beziehungsweise das heißt hören
moses hat zum Beispiel ein Stück für
mich geschrieben wenn Liebe ihren Willen
kriegt wo man wirklich am meisten von
dieser Spannbreite mitbekommt mir ist es
gar nicht so aufgefallen das haben wir
dann eben alle anderen gesagt wie krass
dieses Lied aussieht wirkt allein
stimmlich und ich hatte darüber
gesprochen dass sie ja du bist einfach
die einzige die so hinbekommen hat ganz
ehrlich also auch so locker das ist so
schwierig Wasser oder doch
schwierig also mir ist es so nicht
aufgefallen jetzt würde ich das dann
natürlich dann so höre verstehe ich das
schon aber es ist für mich was einfach
ein wahnsinnig haben wollte und dann
habe ich gesagt
und da gibt's nicht so eine Angst
mein Gott wo geht denn das da runter und
gar nicht überhaupt nicht so so
aufgefallen gar nicht weil es gibt ja
große Sängerin da wundert man sich
manchmal dass das veröffentlicht wird
die singen tief aber da ist halt nicht
mehr viel Volumen da und bei dir ist das
immer da ja zum Glück also zum Glück
gibt es dann auch andere Künstler die
uns solche Sachen schreiben
und das passt dann ist das deine
Erfüllung
würde ich schon sagen also solange es so
weit ich es wird immer mehr zu Erfüllung
also gerade diese Platte ist jetzt für
mich
die beste es ist meine steigert sich ich
hoffe eine noch bessere machen zu können
danach aber einfach vom Gefühl weil es
wirklich so viel von mir ist und jetzt
auch von anderen Künstlern die die so
viel von mir da rein getragen haben ja
also von ihrem Beobachtung her weißt du
was mich angeht und das ist schon
umgesetzt haben ist
es ist schon es geht auf jeden Fall die
richtige Richtung okay das heißt der
Titel mir so nah ist wirklich stimmig
und aktuell auch
was ist das was da so nah bei dir ist
leben diese ganzen Umstände bzw die
diese positiven Dinge die gerade
passieren also es war so so lange
warten schon ziemlich negativ dann
spielt man auch immer selber mental und
irgendwann kommt ein Punkt das passiert
irgendwas gar nicht gerechnet hätte in
meinem Fall ist es wirklich Familie die
wir unter anderem auch gefunden haben
und und wie alle aufeinander reagiert
haben obwohl man sich noch nie richtig
gesehen hat das heißt das ist da
passiert was ist da passiert wir haben
sehr viele Geschwister meiner Mutter
gefunden und die sind überwiegend alle
in Amerika verstreut und sind
zusammengekommen letztes Jahr
und es war ein unglaubliches familiäres
Gefühl also es werden die nie getrennt
gewesen
da hat man dann auch sich selbst in
manchen Menschen wiedererkannt ist nicht
immer die positivsten
ich bin doch nicht so komisch und wenn
es es ist in der Familie
also man fühlt sich dann auch nicht mehr
so
allein wenn man dann plötzlich so viele
Menschen die haben auch ähnlich sehen
Sie man ist sich ähnlich man geht auch
ganz anders miteinander um und das war
so eine unausgesprochene Liebe war dann
tatsächlich einfach da und sind wirklich
sehr sehr inspiriert kommt man da ich
sage mal
Wurzeln mehr
du kannst mir folgen ja ja und was sind
denn deine Wurzeln was hast du da
erkannt
also meine also es scheint sehr viele
Menschen
ziemliche Kämpfer zu sein und auch ein
sehr sehr hartnäckig
also ich war da echt
was uns los wie sie ihre eigenen
Geschichten so überwältigt haben und es
aber auch nicht so im Vordergrund
gestellt haben so oh das und das ist mir
passiert so eine eher diese Einstellung
das habe ich überstanden und das war so
so ein Dreh das ach ja so kann man das
auch sehen
Punkt das heißt das sind Menschen die
eine positive Sichtweise auf
Schicksalsschläge haben
und hat sich das dadurch bei dir
geändert oder hast du dich bestätigt
das ist einfach man weiß ja sowas aber
wenn man das nicht richtig realisiert
oder auch genügend Menschen haben die
alle sowas Vorleben können und plötzlich
habe ich da die wie viel sind das wir
haben zwei die sogar noch fehlen das
waren glaube ich sechs Stück und dann
noch mit deren Familie und hast du
einfach da gegen so eine Wand kommst du
gar nicht an
ja und das fehlte dir vorher weil du in
Deutschland eher isoliert hattest und
diesen Kontakt nicht hattest zur Familie
oder
war für mich Familie vor allem mein
Großvater ich habe Cousinen die die mich
dann machen mit einbezogen haben vor
Jahren zwei ganz süße aber das ist das
war so also wo man sagen kann das ist
tatsächlich Familie also wenn man dann
auch mal Sachen miteinander aushält oder
also so und wirklich einfach nur da ist
auch wenn sich so einfach ist und
einfach weiß okay dann jetzt auch keine
Seiten genommen sondern einfach da wird
jetzt noch gearbeitet das würde
funktioniert also das
ist tatsächlich Familie zumindest
empfinde ich das so und das Gefühl ist
dann noch mal gestärkt worden
was hat das dann für dein Leben bedeutet
was hat dir das für ein Schub gegeben
oder in welche Richtung unglaublichen
Halt gegeben allein dass sie dann auch
alle schon von mir wussten
ich bin einer der wenigen Nichten also
nicht alle haben Kinder deswegen würde
ich da auch noch wirklich Gottes Willen
sie haben immer wir müssen jetzt die
letzten 30 Jahren nachholen ich werde
also mal kurz für zwei Wochen
hast aber sehr genossen
war einfach einfach zu wissen wenn man
sich auch wieder hierher kam zu wissen
was
für Menschen ich da noch mal hinter mir
stehen habe das ist ein ganz anderes
Gefühl das kann ich gar nicht gar nicht
richtig beschreiben es war auch erst
unwirklich also ich muss mich da immer
noch daran auch erinnern dass ich nicht
alleine für mich Kämpfe sondern dass das
da andere Menschen sind ja regelmäßig
anrufen die mich ausfragen die jetzt
auch noch alle auf Facebook sind und
aufpassen und alles wissen und sogar
mehr wissen als ich sie soll ja du bist
ja morgen da und da und mich auch Besuch
also sie erhalten noch diesen Kontakt
und ich ich kann es nicht beschreiben es
ist neu ja was für viele Menschen
vielleicht selbstverständlich ist hast
du als was neues
genau also einmal diese Rückhalt das ist
plötzlich da dass man so eigentlich nur
von anderen mitbekommt okay wie war das
denn dann in deiner Kindheit ohne diesen
Rückhalt wie hast du so die Welt gesehen
war das hast du was du so hast du dich
als Einzelkämpferin gefühlt oder ja
schon also ich habe also mein Rückhalt
war mein Großvater der aber selbst sich
seinem Rückhalt von sich rausgezogen hat
also musste so viele Sachen hat das
alles auch selber geschafft das war doch
so okay wir sind Einzelkämpfer und los
geht's und dann kommen plötzlich diese
Menschen und sagen man muss das nicht
alleine machen man muss es nicht alleine
durchstehen und das ist wirklich eine
ganz andere Einstellung wie gesagt und
ich mich immer noch gewöhnen muss
okay den du vielleicht am Anfang deiner
Karriere noch nicht hattest so nee man
hat sich denn dann automatisch gesucht
ich meine ich habe mich dann halt hinter
Moses versteckt da musste stehen
aber ich glaube das sind auch Sachen die
man sich dann die man dann unbewusst
macht
schon von vorne rein in dem Maße auch
gehabt und so intensiv
ist das schon gewesen wäre also so wie
es ist ist es völlig in Ordnung ich
genieße es auch und es ist toll auch so
eine Steigerung zu erleben
aber ich ich sehe das natürlich in
anderen die schon viel früher so ein
selbstverständliches Selbstvertrauen
haben und wo auch die diese Liebe und
und diese Rückhalt so selbstverständlich
ist es sind einfach anders meinst du
denn du hättest vielleicht früher was
anders gemacht wenn du das schon so
empfunden hättest
gibt Situationen wo du gesagt nee das
hätte ich jetzt heute würde ich das
nicht mehr machen
ich glaube wenn ich diese Menschen schon
früher in meinem Leben gehabt hätte wäre
einiges anders gewesen
also ich habe eine Tante die mich die
ganze Zeit wieder meine Verträge sind
also da kommt plötzlich Sachen von
Menschen die sich dann so damit
involvieren weil sie aufpassen also ich
habe plötzlich ganz viele Glucken die
die aufpassen und das hatte ich davon
nicht so das war okay jetzt machen wir
auch gut Glück und müssen halt
irgendwelchen Anwälten Vertrauen und
irgendwelchen Menschen sind weil sie
sonst auch niemand auskennt und und ich
glaube wenn die die hätten dann gleich
so weil es aber auch gängiger ist in den
Staaten also
wäre vielleicht ein bisschen anders
gelaufen aber trotzdem ist es so gut wie
es ist also ich beschwere mich nicht
das Gefühl du warst vorher im
Haifischbecken den Haien ausgeliefert
die dich nein das hatte ich wirklich nie
also manchmal erfährt man dann im
Nachhinein dass das da ein paar Dinge
vielleicht hätten besser laufen können
aber es hat mir jetzt nicht so geschadet
dass ich jetzt sag oh mein Gott das ist
ja alles gut gelaufen war wirklich so
ein in Ordnung so ich konnte mich ja aus
diesem Haifischbecken zumindest mental
auf jeden Fall zurückhalten ich hatte ja
den größten Hai
ja so gesehen
ja ich verstecke mich da dahinter
gut aber jetzt brauchst du ihn so nicht
mehr essen super Kollege aber du musst
dich nicht okay
der der der Sachen schreibt die ich auch
zu Glashaus Zeiten schon wollte aber
meine kann ich nicht will ich nicht und
jetzt so so wunderschöne Sachen dabei
entstanden für mich darauf bin ich auch
sehr stolz super das klingt sensationell
ich bin gespannt wie das weitergeht
vielen Dank danke